qué balance entonces podemos hacer de
estos juegos y cómo queda el medallero
pero primero comenzamos por el balance
de raúl creo que fue positivo para japón
positivo para tokio para haber realizado
estos juegos unos juegos que fueron
controvertidos desde sus inicios primero
por el tema de la pandemia y luego por
una serie de situaciones extradeportivas
escándalos mayoritariamente que se
fueron presentando a lo largo de la
organización de los mismos pero que poco
a poco tanto las autoridades de tokio de
japón y del comité organizador pudieron
ir solventando para llevar a cabo estos
juegos respecto al medallero tu segunda
pregunta creo que lo importante en este
caso es la recuperación que tuve eeuu
eeuu
quizás no tuvo los juegos deseados
perdieron o dejaron de ganar muchas
medallas en disciplinas que eran
dominantes como la natación pero en la
última jornada pudieron reponerse y
superar a china en cuanto al medallero
general
así es luís y estos juegos se llevan a
cabo en con muchos tropiezos por cuenta
de esta pandemia de kobe 19 le pregunto
que podemos hablar sobre este tema y
también el desempeño de los
latinoamericanos
respecto al tema de kobe 19 fue un mucha
la preocupación que se generó al
principio sobre todo a días de inaugurar
los juegos cuando empezaron a llegar las
delegaciones porque se empezaron a
generar contagios en cuanto a los
atletas y también en delegaciones hubo
casos de atletas que no pudieron
presentarse el más sonado fue el del
español jon round en el golf que no pudo
estar en los juegos por contagiarse de
kobe 19 días antes de compensar la
competición en este sentido creo que
pudieron también bajar los niveles de
contagio y de esta manera desarrollar
unos juegos seguros que fue el
planteamiento de tokio en todo momento
por otro lado en cuanto al desempeño de
américa latina' creo que fue
extraordinario con países que lograron
su primer oro en estos juegos y también
otros que mejoraron su actuación
respecto al río 2016 ahora alves los
próximos juegos se llevarán a cabo en
parís el año 2024 cómo se prepare la
ciudad para este gran evento deportivo
bueno la ciudad ya se viene preparando
en cuanto a lo que son las instalaciones
que van a albergar
una de las disciplinas que están
formando parte del programa también hay
que desarrollar que en cuanto a los
atletas tendrán un ciclo olímpico más
corto puesto que en los juegos ahora
tendrán un año menos de preparación
entonces va a ser un poco acelerado para
muchos pero también hay que resaltar que
tokio fue la despedida para algunos
entonces va a ser el inicio de un nuevo
proceso para varios de los atletas
también estar a la expectativa de nuevas
disciplinas que van a estar presentes